do you think people that are starting
comedy now
are
is it gonna be a completely different
world where i i tend to think now
people that are starting are gonna have
to go to the internet
and and almost the same way that you
were taking a beating at open mics and
things like that
they're almost going to have to take a
beating online
in front of a digital audience to build
their thing because the
the mainstream or the legacy industry
seems to of comedy seems to be dying so
even though they'll be getting good at
stand up on the side
if they don't have other components what
do you mean by the mainstream of comedy
meaning that the idea of moving to new
york or la and doing 20 sets a week
and then getting the montreal comedy
festival and then getting the booker at
the club to see you and like you and
then getting a special on hbo all that
seems to be dying i know so many people
with our specials and nobody's watching
them right or so many people with late
night tv shows like they're hosting them
and no one cares yeah that's true and
and they're not making that much money
and it seems to be a smaller and smaller
circle of people that this is mattering
to
every day the internet's expanding it
seems to be getting bigger and bigger
and the people that have a platform
online a digital platform seem to be
getting more and more attention so to me
isn't there an
inevitable shift coming to where comics
really are just gonna have to compete
digitally i think the digital aspect of
it is the best way to promote themselves
for sure right whether it's through
putting their stuff online on a youtube
or a rumble or
instagram or whatever they're doing
yeah why are you it's a news story that
you're on getter well the news story is
their their [ __ ] amount of people
that signed up increased by 1 150 or
something yeah you have like 20 you have
like eight nine million followers on
getter yeah it's not real though is it
because gender doesn't even have nine
million people no really yeah yeah it's
it's very it's so there's [ __ ] with
that this is where the [ __ ] is they
take all my twitter followers so i my
twitter follows like 7.8 million yeah
and then they port those over so i
started out with 7.8 no
so whatever i have now if i have eight
it's like really i have two hundred
thousand so get her yes fugazi
and every time i post on twitter it
posts automatically on getter oh
interesting yeah like it's automatically
done yeah so it's just harvesting your
tweets and i don't know how to get off
like if i get off a getter
you have to you have to sit down with
marjorie taylor green personally
and she's got to tell me all about
what's in the basement
she's got to take you down the rabbit
hole then you come out the other side of
ghetto
but yeah it seems to me that like the
business is kind of dying i don't think
it is you don't think it is no no i
disagree i prove it is this no no no
that aspect of the business as far as
like montreal comedy festival and stuff
like that being beneficial that's true
that's dying right but podcasts have
taken their place right you know
comedians now like brian simpson who's
got his new brilliant netflix one of the
best yeah he's working with me this
weekend he's one of the best i love him
to death and he now that he has this
huge netflix special that killed and
he's been on my podcast a couple of
times he's got a career right he's
killing it right he will continue to
kill it yeah so this is where the the
but he's not as big as rambu
so my point is that who's that rambu's a
minecraft streamer joe stop pretending
you don't know who he is is that real
yeah he's a minecraft streamer my point
is that
things are moving quickly we can't
compare ourselves to minecraft i
understand that but
i'm just saying
yes we can
i was in the newspaper the other day and
doctor disrespect has a book
mr beast has a burger well mr beast
deserves a birthday he's a brilliant guy
he's got a creature good it's a great
show yeah he does he does he's a
visionary it's a smart thing that he
does he spends a shitload of money on
his show well that's what i mean these
are the new stars well that's jesus
those are the new stars in terms of like
that would be he would be a reality tv
star
like 10 years ago for sure now he's a
youtube star but now he's his own
[ __ ] boss and he's doing it the right
way which is why it's so successful the
same thing with your podcast imagine a
world where an executive bankrolls your
podcast and says oh are you going to sit
together with your friend ben and you're
gonna wear cop sunglasses yeah and
you're gonna talk [ __ ] about the whole
world yeah what are you talking about
yeah you want me to pay for that i get
to give several executives that would
fund it but they're all disgraced
angelo mazzillo at country ride dickfold
at lehman brothers exactly yes i know
for sure
the world has changed but there are new
avenues that are available right but the
world of comedy remains in clubs like
you yeah that is true you gotta be able
to get on stage and play and we both
yeah that is the most important one of
the most important things yes it's like
i'm not giving that up like stand up no
one's [ __ ] awesome and yes that is
always going to be a thing that i like
to see and it's always going to be a
thing that i like to do and it's always
going to be a thing where people want to
go see a comic they want to go live it's
a fun thing to do don't you want to get
to the point where people know you so
well from the internet that when you get
on stage they just clap for 45 minutes
you don't even have to write material
and then you can just leave you can kind
of wave like princess diana used to do i
don't think that happens i don't think
you ever get no of course not i feel the
heat after about 15 minutes of course i
know of course you do i get nervous as
soon as i walk on stage
i get the mic i got
it's the biggest high you ever have it's
the best thing it's the best art form
it's also the best thing for the
audience like in terms of like it's the
most audience member yeah i love
watching someone kill it's fun that's
right when i laugh hard like i'm
laughing hard it's only killing but
you're also from a generation of people
that leaves their house that's true
there's a whole generation of people
that are scared to leave the room well
let alone the house my audience
quit you have to keep evolving you
should be on twitch you should be
streaming i'm on spotify you're a young
man my evolution you can keep going
where's my deal what did they tell us
[ __ ] off for the ninth time all cause i
wasn't telling you to [ __ ] i could
attack the ceo i said he was a pedophile
it was a joke that's not real no one can
have fun anymore i think he said i'm a
pedophile too yeah i'm i don't know if i
did that but i said that the ceo
was uh something or other but so he's
mad at you no he's not mad but
apparently because they have you they
don't need me yeah because we have
overlap and they're still going by they
should get you they're still going by
the old numbers that say that this
show's bigger than mine those are the
old numbers that's last week this show's
not even on youtube anymore i keep
telling them it's true it's not even on
youtube they go oh no it doesn't matter
we have the internals in your bed
honestly the the beautiful thing about
spotify has been the lack of censorship
and the lack of fear of having episodes
pulled and all that [ __ ] modify has been
amazing and in the beginning people
thought they were going to be worse than
youtube they've actually conversely been
so much better yeah there's been so much
better i think that's just because
people always they
they hate change they hate any kind of
like that's right
thing that's happening and you know also
it's like they hate they hate someone
doing well so someone gets something
it's a crazy deal and they're making all
this money like oh it sucks now i used
to watch now i hate it yeah [ __ ] it's
the worst she's sold out normal
so and also
in the beginning i did lose a lot we
lost like 50 of our audience like almost
right away yeah jamie was in a frothy
panic really look at him well he's got
so many other opportunities frothy panic
yeah um but a year later we've got as
much if not more we have more right and
it's better it's bigger than where it's
ever been it's just it just had to like
this is just what happens immediately
i'm just like good let me be ten percent
less famous right you'll be right happy
for 25. give me 25 less fame yeah and
more money well that's not the way it's
worked out
that well that's funny
you're like let's be a little less
controversial a little less famous
and then on the other side of it you
have fouchy trying to drone you outside
of your house